jingle bells jingle bells jingle scialpi
del bue vaio maron
quant'è bello sto al bere che mi ha
portato mio padre cioè la portata lo
store tutta la punta benissimo per la
portato il mio papà perché in casa mia
era natalizia tanto quanto un cimitero
comunque sia ragazzi ben retribuito
questo un video sono tali j
e oggi siamo in un nuovo login natalizio
che aspetta che posiziona questa cosa
così sullo sfondo tutto natalizio e
facciamo un video tutto bello di natale
o québec è bello fare i video con uno
sfondo natalizio si posso sembrare quasi
un vero youtube
vorrei ragazzi miei iniziare con la
parata della settimana questa settimana
non sola panart perché ho fatto talmente
tante cose che non ho avuto tempo di
guardare le fan art che ci stavano tra
le quali registrare 250 video che dire
epici e poco quindi dovete aspettare
l'inizio né vacanze di natale perché ci
saranno dei video quindi ragazzi questo
weekend scorso ho fatto una pausa dalle
registrazioni dalle varie registrazioni
dei video perché era il compleanno di
sasha e siamo andati a casa di stage a
farli una festa a sorpresa vi lascio con
delle clip della serata per una serata
memorabile dicevo non è il classico
compleanno
[Musica]
quando si organizza una festa in casa o
email
ma come cazzo grazie ai bar quello
grazie mamma la forza che bordello chi è
che rimette in ordine
vabbè band di ragazzi muta questo
momento io sono mai gel siamo a casa di
sasha perché è il suo compleanno non so
se si era capito come è partito il drop
dalla con la fandango
basta grazie ciao
maiani auguri sasha no face computer
marcatori cosa è successo ma che bozza
versace verso ce n'è un altro po di
pizza
[Musica]
proprio dai semplici togli la festa è un
cazzo schifo c'è una patatina per terra
e l'ho appena toccata papa dici la tua
papà grazie papà devo prendere questa
cosa ed è segnalata la serata e siamo
usciti non siamo arrivati a questo punto
ci spiegate
mi spiegate
siamo finiti and go kart e un macello
pfeiffer sono i poveri che sbrigano il
vetro con l'acqua i ricchi la spina e
champagne con lo champagne e big money
kuhlau 58ancora culo sporco
dopodiché ragazzi siamo andati a vedere
la partita dopo il giorno con tutto quel
giorno perché sono mica è impossibile
tre mandati
qualche giorno dopo a vedere la partita
di champions della juventus perché
giocava appunto a torino ci credete che
io anche se sono di torino non ho mai
visto non avevo mai visto una partita
della juve allo stadio e niente ho fatto
un paio di riprese anche lì in giovani
ciao
[Musica]
non abbiamo beccati va della sacal e mio
zio
ciao zio saluta ciao certo che anche mio
zio non sono mai venuto allo stadio in
vita mia sono di torino sono la
disgrazia ma questo lo stadio la prima
volta che lo vedo
[Musica]
porca [ __ ] ma in realtà credevo ci
fosse molta
e cazzo sopra jazz da 77
ok
e la prima volta che vengo allo stadio e
pensavo fossi molto ma molto più
incasinato invece no
e tranquillo a parte ogni tanti cori
tira
le torri porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ]
già il match ci abbandonano un minuto
prima della fine del primo tempo perché
non sono veri tifosi perfetto c'è
stefano che adora l'odore della benzina
e quindi quando siamo parcheggiati al
benzinaio mette la testa fuori per
annusare la benzina paga e drogato
normale youtube faccio il benzinaio c'è
veramente siamo dati avere una partita
di champions league che io a malapena so
cos'è un pallone però ho fatto un video
sulla crossbar challenge e ho fatto sei
milioni di views ronaldo melo pupa e
quindi ragazzi niente io vorrei
concludere dicendo vi che mica quanto
scopo che ci credete che ho registrato
questo video qui sono stato in venti
centimetri di divano e non so neanche
come cazzo fatto prova cosa non si fa
per lo sfondo natalizio e l'acqua il
marron glacé che ho comprato al negozio
di dolci non comprati tre pacchi perché
io mangio i dolci e non ingrasso sucate
io vengo a napoli vorrei dire però che
cosa sta per uscire però poi rovinò la
sorpresa e poi non funziona tanto il
clic bait se ve lo dico prima quindi
facciamo che il numero di core aiuto
ragazzi ma l'argomento è un mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come video
no ho cambiato è giusto anche i vari
social che come lo divido stata nella
sezione giochi di schieri ci vediamo al
prossimo video devo uscire quindi
chiuderò questo video danno una facciata
la videocamera che ormai lo chiudo più
così che col telecomando da ragazzi
catania che botta cazzo sismica cazzo è
successo